- Hurry up, motherfucker,
before somebody sees us!
You know your husband
drives a Guber!
- Aye, don't look at me.
I'm just the side nigga.
I'm gon' suck the shit out
them titties later.
I promise you.
- [laughing]
[phone line trilling]
- This is Jamal,
don't nobody leave voicemails.
Text me, bitch.
[beep]
- I'm at Lo Lo's, Jamal.
I told you I was doing
a special open mic just for you.
You better be out there,
motherfucker!
Smooches.
- Are you ready for your next
spoken word artist?
Give it up for
Generykah Badon't.
[crowd whooping]
- Side Boos, how y'all feel?
- Whoo!
- You tell 'em!
- Wifed-up nigs on the low low,
y'all all right?
- Huh?
- What?
- This one's for you, Jamal.
♪ I'm gettin' tired of yo shit ♪
♪ We ain't never seen
in public ♪
[crowd cheering]
- Sit yo monkey-ass down.
- ♪ And every time
I come around ♪
♪ They say you ain't here, dead,
or you way out of town ♪
♪ But you don't like
that I'm fat ♪
♪ With titties in the back ♪
♪ I think I'm tired of callin',
Jamal ♪
[together]
♪ Don't call 'em ♪
- ♪ Nigga,
I'm 'bout to be gone ♪
[cheers and applause]
[microphone feeds back]
Jank Eye Jarvis?
What the fuck you doin' here?
- What, 'cause I got a janky eye
I can't have a side boo?